hello I'm Mariana how was lunch I hope
you don't come to nap here so we're
gonna stretch a little bit please
everybody I don't see you stretching uh
yeah very good okay so we can start okay
at the beginning of the twentieth
century between 1906 and 1907 Ferdinand
de Saussure as Swiss linguist and
semiotician gave lectures about
linguistics at the University of Geneva
in 1960 after six years dead he students
Charles Bailey and Albert I don't know
how to pronounce his name so such a
higher published course in general
linguistics based on their notes from
such your lectures this is a moment
where modern linguistics especially
instructor linguistics was born before
severe languages and their structures
were studied by many people in different
ways the first register of it is from
the 6th century before Christ in India
when panini formulated 4000 rules of
sang Sanskrit morphology plateau in
Hicks in his catalyst dialog mentions
that words are attained eternal concepts
and exists in the world of ideas which
is really poetic by the way in 2080
before Christ the University of
Alexandria was founded Ingrid was talk
to other speakers from this time the
word grammar was first used and it meant
the art was writing in the Middle Ages
languages were studied under the name of
phonology moving forward in the 18th
century jacob grimm
wrote dutch agrammatic and i'm sorry for
my accent with german which is
considered the first great scientific
linguistic work word in the world
bill - humboldt defined human language
as a rule governing governed system with
which we can create an infinite number
of sentences use
and finitude grammatical rules if we go
back to the breaking point
when modern linguistics was founded by
scissored an essential concept was
created the concept of signed which is
the combination of signified and
signifier signified is the idea or the
concept and signifier is an expression
making it easier signified it's what is
behind the world the concept and
signifiers is how with praises we
express it meaning with writing letters
or with sounds for example because there
are other ways to do it forces here
science should be studied
psychologically because science can be
defined just when they are come in
contact with other signs if starting
with a structural isms many different
movement movements were developed and
then we found norms Stransky and the
general janitor of division I'm so sorry
I'm so nervous okay in the second half
of the 20th century norm tom skerritt
created this movement is based in
sentence in syntax but also address
other aspects of languages like
phonology and morphology according to
Chomsky the first thing linguistics
should study is describing the universal
grammar which is a set of syntactic
rules Universal for all humans and other
underlying grammars of all human
languages so behind all the languages
there's a grammar and this grammar is
universal for all of them Chomsky
affirms that the universal grammar is in
native to the human brain that means
that at some point we turn on the switch
and then we gay we get the languages
according to this movement
the primary student must be defined but
a dependency stream as I wanted we can
see in the slide with a famous phrase
created by Chomsky a phrase Cintiq
syntactically perfect but with nonsense
on the opposite side of Chomsky Michel
holiday published in 1985
an introduction to functional grammar
these theories are based on social
interaction and the linguistic theory is
just one part of them so there are many
and one of them is linguistics a
language is defined by holiday as a
social semiotic system meaning that it
evolves as a system of meaning potential
or as a set of resources which influence
what a speaker can do with language in a
particular particular social context in
other words languages are more than a
set of of sentences but an exchange of
meaning in interpret interpersonal
social context based on choices made by
its speakers so a language is used by
speakers and the context and what is
behind that it's what it makes it
functional so if we move forward
languages are started in five levels or
layers we can start describing them from
the smallest unit of study to the
biggest in this case phonetics and
phonology is in charge of the study of
the sound of a human speech phonetics
studies that human sounds how they are
produced transmitted and received its
unit of study is called phonemic and
it's defined as perceptual unit of sound
of sound that distinguish a word in a
specific language one on the other hand
phonology classifies the dough sounds
within the system of a particular
language so phonetics splits all the
sounds that humans make and phonology
puts them together in a system for
example English front phonetics and
phonology system has 44 sounds if we
follow with a next small smallest unit
of language we find morphology which is
the study of words how they are formed
and related to each other
according to morphology words are built
using the smallest unit of meaning so
morphemes for example if we have the
word worker
it's made by the root work and ER at the
end so a suffix that gives the label of
now syntax is the branch of linguistics
that studies phrases meaning the set of
rules of and principles that govern the
structure of phrases and sentences the
style of syntax looks at the ways in
which the words can be ordered and
combine to combine to transmit a proper
meaning so syntax studies sentences but
also phrases what does that mean
the phrase doesn't need to have a verb
but a sentence does for example if I say
blue garland is a phrase in a sentence
is the blue garden is wet for example
semantics cares about how many words in
a human language in a basic way so the
literal meaning of a word is considered
principle it as part of the human
language system on the other hand
pragmatics can cut constant craze sorry
concentrate on how the basic meaning is
used in practice and how the context
affects it so pragmatics explains how
the talkers overcome ambiguities since
the meaning relates also on the manner
the plays the previous knowledge and the
context of a communication in the NLP
and NLU world we use different models
for different texts tasks for example
language understanding topic modeling
sentiment analysis and chatbots
one of those models is a popular word -
Bek which produces word embeddings each
word embeddings or representation is
generated by using the quartz context or
set of nearby words pragmatics
pragmatics is used since the
representation of the word is given by
its context and semantics since its
since each embedding represents the
literal meaning of a world as we can see
word embeddings are
used by multiple linguistic concepts to
analyze a word by combining many
contextual words mappings a pragmatic
phase approach is used a semantic space
approach is used because each mapping
represents the literal interpretation of
the world when we talk about speech
recognition engines many api's are
available for the usage but how do they
work and how linguistic symbols in the
process when we speak we create
vibrations in the air for speech
recognition those vibrations are sampler
and digitalized by a computer by taking
precise measurements of the wave and
frequent at frequent intervals the sound
is filtered so we remove unwanted noises
and normalize so we have the constant a
constant level of sound it's also
adjusted because of the speed the speed
of the speaker is different in different
contest after design notes are divided
into smaller segments segments as short
as a few hundred of seconds or even
thousand in the case of plots of
contacts a constant sounds for example B
and T are producing with obstruction of
the airflow in the vocal tract how will
filter a normalized and divided sounds
are matched to template within the
speech recognition system in the correct
language the templates are phenomenal
Fano means for a specific language in
the case of English split sounds are
compared and match with 44 sentiments
that are part of the English
phonological system
let's go finally to the universal
language model fine tuning from for text
classification from Sebastian brother
and Jeremy Howard this method involves
fine tune it a pre trained model trained
in on a wiki text 103 data set to a new
data set in such a manner that it does
not forget what is previously previously
learned language modeling can be
considered account a counterpart of
imagenet for NLP
it captures in general properties of a
language and provides an enormous amount
of data which can be said to another
downstream NLP task
what does capture general property
properties means so the language model
learns the structure of a language
indicate in this case English a
structure in how the words are put
together and the relationship that they
have with each other does this sound
familiar to you I hope it does because
as we said before linguistics and study
the structure of words and how they
relate to each other the fields that do
that are morphology and syntax the
hierarchical structure is also captured
by the language model and it's described
by the syntax when we get to understand
in which level we need to work to reach
our goal then it's easier to recognize
the tool we need to use for each task so
many data scientists can better navigate
in the NLP ecosystem and that's it thank
you very much
[Applause]
we do have plenty of time for questions
hi thank you for great talking thank you
also for I take it your first time
speaker yeah here he is fantastic
I was wondering you mentioned holidays
work in linguistics and the sort of
conversational aspects of language and I
was wondering if you have any thoughts
or like a take on how the NLP world
relates to that because the language
modeling stuff and were Tyvek and a lot
of that work is fairly static and
doesn't take into account that sort of
the speech act and and how context
changes in a conversation and so on so a
it's a very fairly general question but
I was just wondering if you have any
kind of take on that so in last week I
was reading this I'm sorry I don't
remember the name of the lady but I was
reading this slides from this teacher in
the Washington University and she says
the problem with a no peace talk in a
way is because we are considering
meaning in a way that it's not the right
way in linguistics so we are considering
that the meaning of a word is given by
its context right and that a language
model can learn what a word means by
their structure but she says that
child's don't learn languages in that
way and I think we have to find a
solution to add on top of the
structure and the context the meaning
and that would be like moving forward I
don't know if I answer your question and
we have more time for questions
hello so I started a bit of an LP at the
University and once it is no what is the
gap between linguistics like pure
linguistics and NLP as a practical
matter well from my point of view so
that the I decided to write this talk
because I have realized that many people
are doing NLP without any language
linguistic knowledge right and if you
don't know how a language work you
cannot improve it if you don't know what
the structure is or how the meaning
works or even the context so I think the
gap is given by the practitioners so me
as a linguistic I should learn more
about the technical part for sure and I
think the practitioners who don't have
any linguistic background she learned
about languages it's not hard but it
takes time and we use languages every
day I one of the things that I have
observed is that we are old speakers
right so we use language and we decide
that we are all linguistics because we
speak but it doesn't work that way I
mean I cannot say I'm a I don't know I'm
a dentist because I have teeth and I
think that the gap starts there Thanks
more please hi thank you for your talk
and I was wondering I heard in a podcast
called data skeptic which is doing like
a very long series on NLP the presenter
said that and all these linguistic
models haven't been so good at like
predicting language like if you think of
I don't know like Google Translate 20
years ago it was like not so great and
now that they like throw like neural
networks I know that stuff at it then
it's getting better and so what is your
take on and like the the theoretical
side of linguistics and how can it or
like why do you think that this
approaches this new technical approaches
have been so successful and how can we
like go back to linguistics and learn
something useful to make those models
better I think modern approaches are
successful in a way because Google
Google Translate it's not that good
because context has been taken into
consideration now I would say I would
include meaning so it's not that we can
take just words right like before or we
can just take the other words that make
a sentence because a computer cannot
understand maybe sarcasm right and
sarcasm comes by the combination of
meanings I started a theory that comes
from chemistry and says that some words
have like balance so you can add many
words and some words don't accept that
maybe that would be a way but I I really
don't know
hello I thank you for your talk
I might actually drop when you put this
oh sure in the first slide and I knew it
was gonna be a great talk do you think
that linguistics
and this approach could be used when
studying programming languages you know
as languages themselves it does I mean
when you study linguistics you study so
programming languages are languages our
artificial languages for their languages
so you understand how grammar and syntax
work and I I think for me it was easier
at least to understand the concepts and
to so when you study linguistics is more
abstract than practical and when you
reach that level then you can understand
programming languages in a better way in
my university back in Venezuela I'm
Venezuelan in the master's degree we
started with people from engineering so
the idea is always to have people from
both disciplines together so we can help
each other thanks for your talk um you
said that language models learn words by
its context and that's not how children
learn words so do you know how children
learn words I think it's more visual
approach you know you have this mapping
of a concept like a tree and then a
symbol like a word and maybe we need
some more visual input for our language
models so the image from the tree I can
go back so here yeah this is like the
typical draw for a sign that we see when
we learned functionalism and the idea is
to show like so how can you describe for
example love it's a concept is an idea
it's not something that we can touch for
sure but it's something that we all know
what it is and the tree in this case
means that that it's in our mind or
whatever and then the letters or the
sounds that we used for children's
that's really I would say complex
so actually noms Chomsky said that
children's understand because they turn
on the switch so we have something in
our inner self that led us and learn in
language and then Holliday said no we
learn languages because we are
functional humans and our beams in
general and we need to tell you
understand the words you learn the words
but you understand the concept they used
the usage and that's how it works I I
think we still don't know how children
learn languages it's really maybe it's
all the theories together in a way I
think it is I think we as humans have
something that let us learn a language
but also that the context and so when
when you you know which boys you should
use to talk in a conference or to your
family or at work and that's functional
I so I if you want I can send you the
link of this women it's really
interesting and she's suggesting many
many many things are there any more
questions we do have time do you think
that in some years time when NLP is
learning for from a lot of text in some
years time there will be a lot of tests
generated already by computers that
language of the our language the
language that we use will be affected by
the fact that we will be greeting staff
generated by computer
I can give you just small background I
was in a meet-up organized by the
publisher of bills item and they were
really proud of generated news with data
and I asked what will happen in 15 years
when most of the your data will be
generated by computers they said we
don't know I would say the same thing so
we get language evolves right how do
they evolve they evolve because we as
humans change and have some new needs
for example how did we introduce in our
languages words like washing machine or
dishwasher it was because women wanted
to have something to wash the clothes
right instead of watching it by hand and
they decided to push and talk a lot of
to the kids about this so I think yes it
can influence a lot because actually we
are using words related so we don't look
for something anymore Google we google
it right and that's like a word that we
learn from a company that its influence
in our life in a really really really
really big way so I think yes because
they like the context in general is
going to change and we are going to
adapt to that new context and it's like
a cycle and that context needs to adapt
to us as well we have time for one last
question
hi thank you for the presentation
so what do you think it's basically
missing in NLP that's that we do have as
people who speak the language or as
linguist so it's like is it the
representation that we have in the mind
for a single word that we are missing in
NLP like currently we have vectorial
representation and in the other side we
also have kind of the Semantic Web or
with the word net this kind of stuff so
which kind of representation do you
think is is kind of making more sense to
a linguist or even which one will be
making progress in the future as I said
before I think it's meaning meaning as a
concept as the tree as the thing that we
have in our mind I don't think we can
just add the meaning of a word with just
the context and the structure so I think
we should add in a way I don't know how
but we we need to find a way to act like
the meaning from the dictionary maybe
okay
let's thank you for your talk let's
thank Mariana again
[Applause]